if that sniper hadn't beaten you to it
i know you would have taken the shuttle
area
no i wouldn't have
did you really expect me to
did you really expect me to cause your
death
what about your kids i don't know
just couldn't get that boy out of my
head
what about me look we both chose each
other over the job
we could never let that happen again
otherwise
can't be partners
i can't believe you're saying that
you and this job are about the only
things i've got anymore
i don't want to wreck that
i can take it
how crazy they could have somebody
watching eyes we must contact with you i
had to come why aren't you answering the
cell phone we gave you
because they took it along with my
wallet there was nothing i could do
about it okay so
take mine and hide it somewhere and that
way i'll tell creighton that you have it
told kathy too i just saw her
she mad she's worse than mad and i can't
say that i blame her
well what the hell am i supposed to do
tell the bad guys i gotta get home for
diaper duty you go undercover again and
don't tell kathy you'll be safer here
than home
call her all right
come on
hey who were you just talking to
what who were you talking to nobody
you wearing ladies panties too
are you ready for me daddy
oh didn't know we were having a party
that's gonna be a hundred to watch
250 to join each
you guys gotta eat huh you got good
chase i'll give you that better out of
you
why so tense um not the night
well guess what you still gotta pay
hey one of your neighbors left me and i
was in the neighborhood sorry give you a
lift to work
elliot what's going on last night munch
offered to give me a lift home
munch did that yeah that's not like him
is it and then this morning you're
offering to drive me to work
in the neighborhood i was uh-huh you
have a sedan with you yep
which means that you drove all the way
up town from the queensborough bridge
dropped off the car picked up the sedan
turned around all the way back downtown
to get here
that's a lot of neighborhood my friend
stop acting like a cop hmm
richard white would like me to do
look i appreciate everyone's concern
but we don't know that white's coming
for me may have gone out of town okay
sure as hell wouldn't drive to queens to
save your ass yeah you would
well maybe that's only because you have
a wife and kid
yeah yeah
stabler
we'll be right there i'll walk you in
i know how to protect myself i'm not a
civilian you're not a superhero either
elliott if i let white change my life in
any way he wins
i'm not gonna let him win this isn't
about winning yeah it is
blink your lights when you get inside
you're just gonna sit here all night
until i do aren't you stubborn son of a
[ __ ]
yes i am
see you tomorrow
how's the baby
pick a name kathy wants to name him
after me
just what the world needs another elliot
stapler
[Music]
welcome to the swing set i'm suzette hi
suzette
uh this is my wife olivia i'm elliott
and you were invited by
a friend of my husband jerry bullard
jerry one of our best members
first time experiencing the lifestyle
is it that obvious you two are gonna
have a lot of fun come on
two club sodas for our new friends
coming right up
so um since this is our first time is it
okay if we just
you know just watch yes absolutely
don't feel any pressure to do anything
you can walk around and mingle
or just sit back relax and drink it all
in
although what you see will be very
tempting
enjoy folks thank you to quenching
your every thirst
uh so uh jerry said that he was gonna be
here tonight have you seen him
not yet but you want to find jerry just
look for cassandra
who's cassandra i'm surprised you didn't
mention her
he probably wants to keep her all to
himself oh
there she is now wow
she's beautiful see what i mean about
[Music]
temptation
elliot olivia i'm glad you can make it
not half as glad as we are
do you mind if your husband buys me a
drink well if he doesn't i will
what do you have scotch on the rock
splash of water come and bite out
so uh suzette says you know our friend
jerry yeah
jerry and i played together just the
other night
i hope he didn't give you all the
details and spoil the fun
jerry didn't say a word except we should
come here and play too
uh
hi hi haven't seen you here before no
i'm olivia i'm a newbie oh we love
newbies
aliens come here
i'm gonna show you something
relax olivia you're safe with us
probably
half of them admitted they couldn't tell
their neighbors from the purp
could you can i what oh your neighbor's
a book why cause i live here
what i'm never home i'm always with you
and people say the suburbs are anonymous
oh now queens is a suburb since when
since we got a little space some trees
grass to mow yeah i got a regular eight
by ten are you out there mowing the lawn
yeah i do
sometimes oh admit it kathy does all the
housework
you're never there okay i admit it
kathy's the man of the house exactly
until dicky's old enough now you're
lucky you got nothing to worry about
definitely got no lawn tomorrow yeah i'm
a regular monk
monket
what
river park pd went to pick up marsden
he jumped bail did a girlfriend know
anything
no do you
what are you saying elliot your family
aren't you
i would never interfere with an
investigation
never
and screw you for saying that
look i'm sorry but i had to ask thanks
for waiting
i discussed your situation with george
wong and at his recommendation
i want you to undergo an independent
psychological assessment
why so i can decide if it's appropriate
for you to continue working together
and if we refuse
you make my decision easy
[Music]
in my opinion detectives benson and
stabler have a degree of mutual
reliance and emotional dependence that
compromises their effectiveness
as police officers
in other words
they're too close
you recommend i split them up
[Music]
if you want to lose your two best
[Music]
detectives
you